ओके
सो वी आर लाइव नाउ आई थिंक वी आर लाइव वी
आर लाइव लेट मी चेक तो चलिए चेक चेक कर
लेता हूं मैं कि लाइव हम आ चुके हैं अभी
या
नहीं सो आई थिंक वी आर
लाइव ओके सो आर वी लाइव लेट मी चेक
एम आ ऑडिबल क्लियर है ऑडियो वीडियो सब
क्लियर है गाइस प्लीज लेट मी
नो प्लीज लेट मी नो क्लियर ऑडियो वीडियो
सब सही है
ना ओके एवरीथिंग इ फाइन
गाइस प्लीज लेट मी नो सब बढ़िया ना लेट मी
चेक ओके आई थिंक वी आर
गुड
या सो सो वी आर एब्सलूट गुड एंड आई होप कि
सभी लोग सुन पा रहे हैं देख पा रहे हैं
अच्छे से तो अटेंडेंस लगा दीजिए जल्दी से
गाइस आप सबका बहुत-बहुत स्वागत है डे थ्री
ऑफ बग बाउंस में जहां पे आज हम बहुत
शानदार चीजें करने वाले हैं सीखने वाले
हैं बहुत सारी चीजें आपको बताऊंगा एंड
बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग सेशन होने वाला है तो
प्लीज लाइव में बने रहिए जैसा आप हमेशा
बनते हैं एंड वी विल बी लर्निंग अ लॉट ऑफ
थिंग्स ठीक है काफी चीजें मैं काफी
इंपोर्टेंट चीजों पर बात भी करने वाला हूं
आज तो हेलो गुड इवनिंग एवरीबॉडी अ लेट
मी सी हाउ मेनी ऑफ यू आर हियर आदित्य सी
एच रितेश गणेश यशवंत गौरव
सनद भाविन हरि ओम ओके अरुण एवरीवन वेलकम
वेलकम टू द सेशन वेलकम चलिए जल्दी से अपने
दोस्तों को भी बता दीजिए जल्दी सेशन के
बारे में उनको शेयर कर दीजिए जहां-जहां आप
शेयर करना चाहते हैं कम्युनिटी में ताकि
उनको पता चले डे थ्री जो है स्टार्ट हो हो
चुकी है आज की तो अब आज के सेशन को बहुत
ज्यादा इंटरेस्टिंग बनाने वाले हैं इन
टॉपिक्स के थ्रू ओस ओ टॉप 10 ओस ब्रोकन
वेब एप्लीकेशन मेटास्प्लोइटेबल इन सबको हम
आज इंक्लूड करने वाले हैं बट आपको एक चीज
और बताऊंगा जो काफी इंपॉर्टेंट है आप सबके
लिए अगर आप बग बाउंट की जर्नी हमारे साथ
कंटिन्यू कर रहे हैं ना आपको अगर मेरे साथ
बग बांटी कंटिन्यू करनी है तो आपको बेसिक
हर एक चीज सीखनी है हर एक चीज जानी है देन
ओनली यू कैन गो टू एडवांस पार्ट देन यू
कैन ओनली बिकम अ प्रो हंटर अगर प्रो बनना
है तो बेसिक सीखना पड़ेगा अगर डायरेक्ट
प्रो बनना है फिर भैया आई कांट मेक यू
प्रो डायरेक्टली वो कोई नहीं आपको बना
सकता है आपको प्रो बनना है यू हैव टू लर्न
बेसिक यू हैव टू गो टू इंटरमीडिएट देन यू
विल बी अ प्रो बग बाउंट हंटर इतना मैं
गारंटी के साथ बोल सकता हूं अब मुझे जल्दी
से बता दो एकदम फास्ट एकदम फास्ट बता दो
आप में से कितने लोगों ने ट्राई हैक मी पे
अकाउंट क्रिएट किया है फ्री अकाउंट या
प्रीमियम कुछ भी चलेगा एंड कितने लोगों ने
उनमें से कोई भी लैब सॉल्व की जो मैंने
प्रीवियस टास्क दिया था ओस टॉप 10 वाली
कितने लोगों ने कर लिया जल्दी मुझे चैट
में बताइए
फटाफट प्लीज हरी अप जल्दी से बता दीजिए
जल्दी चैट में आई एम सींग एवरीवनस चैट सो
लेट मी नो इन द चैट एवरीवन प्लीज जल्दी
जल्दी जल्दी फास्ट प्लीज जल्दी बताइए
कितने लोगों ने करा है आई एम फाइन थैंक
यू गुड
कितने लोगों ने करा कितने लोगों ने नहीं
करा वो भी
बताइए
ओके
ओके ओके तो मैं देख रहा हूं यहां पे काफी
लोगों ने करा है कुछ लोगों ने नहीं भी करा
है चलो कोई बात नहीं जो भी बताना है
ऑनेस्टली बताना है वेरी ऑनेस्ट वेरी
ऑनेस्ट प्लीज आप ऑनेस्टली बताइए प्लीज जो
भी ठीक है ओके आईव डन ठीक है काफी लोगों
ने करा है एंड कुछ लोगों ने नहीं भी करा
है राइट चलिए कोई बात नहीं जिन्होंने नहीं
करा प्लीज रिपीट प्लीज कीजिए बहुत ज्यादा
इंपॉर्टेंट है मैं आपको बार-बार बोलता हूं
ना मैं आपको बार-बार शुरू से कर डे वन से
बोल रहा हूं ट्राई हैक मी इज द मोस्ट
इंपॉर्टेंट थिंग यू हैव टू डू आपको ट्राई
हैक मी पे आना है फ्री अकाउंट क्रिएट करना
है एंड जैसा कि मैंने बोला है वो करना है
ओस टॉप 10 का ये याद रखिएगा हालांकि मैं
कुछ डिस्कशन इस पर करने वाला हूं कि क्यों
मैंने आपको ये बोला है यह ओस टॉप 10 क्यों
जरूरी है देखो तुम्हें अगर ऐसे कोई बग
हंटर बनना है ना इफ यू वांट टू बिकम अ बग
हंटर लाइक कि आप एक बग हंटर तो हो लेकिन
आपको ओस के बारे में ज्यादा आईडिया नहीं
है तो आप ऐसे बंटर बनोगे जिसको सिर्फ
डुप्लीकेट्स मिलेंगे और उसका लॉजिक क्लियर
नहीं होगा किसी भी वनबिल के लिए वो कुछ
ज्यादा वैलिड पॉइंट नहीं रख पाएगा किसी
वनबिल के लिए उसको पता ही नहीं होगा कौन
सी वनबिल पे कैसे हंट करना है क्या फाइंड
करनी है उसमें या किस तरीके से अप्रोच
करना है और इसीलिए ओस टॉप 10 इज वेरी वेरी
इंपॉर्टेंट मैं यकीन के साथ आपको बोल रहा
हूं हूं ना कि अगर आप कॉर्पोरेट में भी
जाते हो ना लेट्स सपोज यू डोंट वांट टू
बिकम अ फ्रीलांस बग हंटर मान लो आप
फ्रीलांस नहीं आप किसी कंपनी के लिए काम
करना चाहते हो इ यू वांट टू गो टू अ
कॉर्पोरेट टू कॉर्पोरेट में आप काम करना
चाहते हो यू वांट टू वर्क फॉर एन एमएनसी
या किसी भी साइबर सिक्योरिटी कंपनी के लिए
वहां जब जाओगे तो आप अपनी जब प्रोफाइल
बताओगे ना भैया उससे पहले आपसे पूछा जाएगा
ओस टॉप 10 आती है मतलब ओस टॉप 10 के बारे
में जानते हो क्या है इसके अंदर जानते हो
यह सारी चीजें जाननी है आपको बतानी पड़ेगी
वहां नहीं बताओगे वो आपको वैल्यू नहीं
करेंगे बिलीव मी आपके लिए ओस टॉप 10 इज
वेरी वेरी मच इंपॉर्टेंट जॉब के लिए खुद
के बिजनेस के लिए या किसी भी फ्रीलांसिंग
के लिए हर जगह ओ टॉप 10 चाहिए भाई बिना ओ
टॉप 10 का बग बाउटी होता ही नहीं है सीधी
सधी बात है यू कांट डू एनीथिंग विदाउट ओस
टॉप 10 लिख लो कहीं पे काम आएगा बहुत
ज्यादा ठीक है ओपन वीपीएन कनेक्ट नहीं हो
रहा क्यों नहीं कनेक्ट हो रहा है भाई ओपन
वीपीएन का मैं मैंने देखा कुछ लोगों के
कमेंट्स आए थे कनेक्ट नहीं हो रहे हैं मैं
चैट में आपको एक लिंक दे रहा हूं उस लिंक
पे जाइए आप लोगों को ना प्रॉब्लम सॉल्विंग
स्किल नहीं है मुझे पता है यू डोंट हैव
एनी प्रॉब्लम सॉल्विंग स्किल्स इनसाइड यू
तो वो भी डेवलप मैं करके रहूंगा उसकी
टेंशन आपको नहीं लेनी है प्रॉब्लम
सॉल्विंग स्किल बहुत बड़ी चीज होती है वो
आप अगर डेवलप कर चुके ना यू डोंट हैव टू
आस्क एनीथिंग फ्रॉम एनी वन राइट इट डाउन
लिख लो भाई लिख लो किसी से पूछने की जरूरत
नहीं पड़ेगी प्रॉब्लम सॉल्विंग स्किल अब
मैंने कमेंट में देखा कि काफी लोगों के
ओपन वीपीएन जो है ना भैया वो नहीं काम कर
रहे हैं वो कनेक्ट नहीं कर पा रहे हैं
क्या कनेक्शन एरर आ रही है यही एरर आ रही
है ना ओपन वीपीएन पियर सर्टिफिकेट वेरी
फिकेशन फेलियर ये एरर आ रही है सबके पीयर
सर्टिफिकेट वेरिफिकेशन फेलियर यही आ रही
है क्या एरर जो कमेंट में मुझे आया था बता
दो जल्दा जल्दी बता दो यही एरर आ रही है
क्या पेयर सर्टिफिकेट वेरिफिकेशन
फेलियर
बताइए
हां google.ca मैं टेंशन मत लो आज शेयर कर
दूंगा यही एरर आ रही है सबके मैक्सिमम
लोगों के यह एरर आ रही है कुछ लोगों के
टाइम आउट एरर आ रही है ठीक है आप एरर को
सर्च करने का सीखिए उसको सॉल्व करने का
सीखिए तभी आप कुछ कर पाएंगे प्रॉब्लम
सॉल्विंग स्किल्स आपकी डेवलप हो पाएंगी
आपको मैं लिंक दे रहा हूं इस लिंक पे
आइएगा यह एक थ्रेड है इस पे आइएगा आपको
यहां पे आपका सॉल्यूशन मिल जाएगा उसको
थोड़ा दिमाग लगा के अप्लाई कीजिएगा एंड यू
विल सॉल्व योर प्रॉब्लम सॉल्व योर
प्रॉब्लम्स ऑन योर ओन ठीक है तो ओपन
वीपीएन एरर
सॉल्यूशन ये सॉल्यूशन अप्लाई कीजिए एंड यू
कैन सॉल्व योर ओन एरर ठीक है रही बात टाइम
आउट एरर की जो भी आपको एरर आ रही है मैं
आपको पहले ही बोल रहा हूं जो भी आपको एरर
आ रही है सेम एरर को
google2 25 30 जितने सॉल्यूशन सब को एक-एक
करके ट्राई करो एक सॉल्यूशन आपके लिए काम
करेगा कई सारे सॉल्यूशंस होते हैं कई सारे
वर्क नहीं करेंगे एक करेगा उसमें क्योंकि
प्रीवियसली आपको जो भी एरर आती है
प्रीवियसली किसी ना किसी यूजर के आ रही
होती है या आई होती है एंड उनका सॉल्यूशन
आपको मिल जाएगा दिस इज कॉल्ड प्रॉब्लम
सॉल्विंग स्किल इसको आपको डेवलप करना है
ठीक है आपको ऐसा स्पून फीडिंग वाला काम
नहीं करना है कि कोई आए चम्मच में ऐसे
देके खिलाए पिलाए एंड बात खत्म नहीं भैया
हम खुद जाएंगे हम खुद निकालेंगे खुद
खाएंगे सीधी सी बात है तभी हम अपने आप को
एक्सपर्ट बोलेंगे अदर वाइज हम अपने आपको
नूब बोलेंगे बस ठीक है
दैट्ची बात करेंगे बहुत शानदार चीज है
इसके बिना बग बाउटी आपकी अधूरी है जैसे आप
हवा के बिना नहीं रह सकते बिना खाई नहीं
रह सकते ठीक है ना वैसे ही आप ओस टॉप 10
के बिना अगर बग हंटिंग कर रहे हैं तो आप
बग हंटिंग कर ही नहीं रहे हैं ठीक है कोई
भी ऐसा बग हंटर उठा के मुझे बताओ जिसको ओ
टॉप 10 नहीं आती है 110 पर वो कुछ भी हो
उसको बग हंटिंग नहीं आती है ही इज नॉट अ
बग हंटा शी इज नॉट अ बग हंटा तो इस टॉप का
मैंने आपको एक लैब दिया था क्या दिया था
भैया लैब ठीक है हां मेरे पास प्रीमियम
वाला ही है भैया आई हैव द प्रीमियम ओके तो
मेरे पास एक लैब मैंने आपको दिया था यहां
पे आपके बोला था ओस सर्च करना है आपको ओ
सर्च करके ओ टॉप 10 का 2021 वाला मैंने
बोला था आप इसको सॉल्व कीजिएगा अब इसको
सॉल्व करने के पीछे रीजन मैं आपको बताता
हूं अब देखो यहां तो ओस के सारे लैब्स है
यहां पे वल जो भी यहां पे आपको वर्क थ्रू
मिल रहे हैं टॉप 20 टॉप 10 के हैं ठीक है
2021 वाले अब इसमें मैंने इसलिए बोला था
कि आपको ओवरऑल आईडिया हो जाएगा कि
एक्चुअली यह चीजें है
क्या यह चीजें है क्या मैं नेक्स्ट सेशन
में इसका आपको प्रैक्टिकल भी बताऊंगा इसका
प्रैक्टिकल भी बताऊंगा ओस पॉप 10 के कि
इसको कैसे प्रैक्टिकल इसको हर एक का जैसे
ब्रोकन एक्सेस कंट्रोल का ठीक है ना
क्रिप्टोग्राफिक फेलियर का इंजेक्शन का यस
ऑथेंटिकेशन का सबका आपको प्रैक्टिकल भी
बताऊंगा लेकिन आपको जब बोला था इसलिए बोला
था कि आप जब इसको पढ़ के समझेंगे ना तो आप
आपका कांसेप्ट बिल्कुल क्लियर हो जाएगा
टोटली क्लियर हो जाएगा एंड तब आपको ज्यादा
मजा आएगा सीधी सी बात है तब आपको ज्यादा
मजा
आएगा ठीक है तो ये चीजें आपको करनी है अब
ये ओस टॉप 10 में ये सारे जो चीजें हैं
क्या है ब्रोकेन एक्सेस कंट्रोल हमारा
पहला पहला दूसरा आपका क्या है
क्रिप्टोग्राफिक फेलियर ठीक है तीसरा
इंजेक्शन चौथा इनसिक्योर डिजाइन
सिक्योरिटी मिस कॉन्फिन वल्नरेबल एंड
आउटडेटेड कंपोनेंट्स देन आइडेंटिफिकेशन
ऑथेंटिकेशन फेलर देन सॉफ्टवेयर एंड डेटा
इंटीग्रिटी फेलर्स देन सिक्योरिटी लॉगिंग
एंड मॉनिटरिंग फेलर्स एंड देन एसएसआरएफ
सर्वर साइड रिक्वेस्ट फॉर जरी अब ये चीजें
जब आप करेंगे तो आपको समझ में आएगा तो आप
अच्छे से आगे समझ पाएंगे जब हम एक-एक करके
इवने बिलिटी पाएंगे ना तो यू विल गेट टू
इट आपको समझ में आने लगेगा काफी लोगों ने
कर लिया है काफी लोगों ने कर लिया है बट
स्टिल जिन्होंने नहीं किया है इनको रिपीट
कीजिए इनको फाइनलाइज कीजिए नेक्स्ट क्लास
के पहले प्लीज कर लीजिएगा अगर आपको चाहिए
कि इनके मैं लैब्स प्रैक्टिकल सॉल्व करके
आपको बताऊं या आपको दिखाऊं वो भी मैं कर
दूंगा यू वांट कि मैं नेक्स्ट क्लास में
इसको प्रैक्टिकली भी दिखाऊं ऐसा आपको
चाहिए जब मुझे बता दीजिए चैट में बता
दीजिए
प्लीज प्लीज लेट मी नो इफ यू वांट अ
प्रैक्टिकल ऑन दिस इन नेक्स्ट
सेशन
इंतजार करो इंतजार करोगे सब सब मिलेगा
नोवा ठीक है मैं आपके कहने से नहीं चलूंगा
मैं अपने अकॉर्डिंग ही चलूंगा आपको इंतजार
करना पड़ेगा ठीक है यहां पे बिगिनर्स के
लिए यह बग बाउंट की फ्री क्लास दी जा रही
है यहां उनके लिए नहीं दी जा रही है जो
ऑलरेडी बग हंटिंग अगर कर रहे हैं या उनको
नॉलेज है अगर उनको इंटरमीडिएट का नॉलेज
ऑलरेडी है बग हंटिंग में और व चाहते हैं
कि मैं एकदम से एडवांस प आ जाऊं तो ऐसा
नहीं होगा आपके लिए सेशन नहीं है एडवांस
पट जब स्टार्ट होगा देना पाइए अभी
बिगिनर्स के लिए जिनको कुछ नहीं नहीं पता
बिल्कुल उनके लिए है यह सीरीज इसलिए फ्री
आपको प्रोवाइड किया जा रहा है ठीक है अदर
वाइज बग हंटर्स या बग हंटिंग के क्लासेस
पेड भी होते हैं बहुत लोग कराते हैं ठीक
है तो इस बात को समझिए
थोड़ा पोट्स फिगर भी आएगी पहले यार पहले
यार आगे तो बढ़ो अभी तो प्री रिक्वे
साइट्स चीजें हैं बहुत सारी चीजें उसको
कंप्लीट तो करते हैं ना है ना
चलो ओके ओके ग्रेट चलिए आप में से कितने
लोग अपने आप को बिगनर मानते हैं बग
बाउंटीज चैट में बता दो जरा जितने लोग भी
मानते हैं जितने लोग भी अभी देख रहे हैं
ना लाइव सभी लोग मुझे बताइए कितने लोग
अपने आप को बिगनर मानते हैं जरा बताइए
मुझे बिगनर या बिगनर अपने आप को बिगनर
मानते
हैं
प्लीज
जितने लोगों जितने लोग हैं सभी लोग बताइए
मैं देख रहा हूं चैट में आ आई एम सीइंग ऑन
द मोबाइल
फोन ओके काफी लोग बिगनर
है
ओके
ओके ओके ठीक है काफी लोग बिगनर हैं कुछ
लोग ठीक है कुछ लोग होंगे इसमें
इंटरमीडिएट लेवल के अब मैं आपको बताता हूं
जो भी आप लोग बिगिनर्स है ना मैं आपको एक
चीज समझा देता हूं उसको समझ लीजिए दिमाग
में डालिए उसको प्लीज मैं आपसे एक
रिक्वेस्ट कर रहा हूं इस रिक्वेस्ट को
मानिए मैं आपके लिए ले आया ना प्रॉमिस
किया था मैंने कि मैं आपको बग बाउंट की
फ्री ट्रेनिंग दूंगा मैं लेकर आया आपके
लिए लेकर
आया मैं रेगुलर क्लासेस भी करा रहा हूं
आपने बोला एंड पेन टेस्टिंग उसकी भी दो
क्लासेस मैंने कराई कराई ना आपकी अरेंज तो
करा दी आपकी अब ये फिर से कंटिन्यू कर
दिया तो अब मेरी भी बात आप मानोगे ना अब
बात यह है कि अगर आप एक बिगनर हो तो जैसे
मैं करा रहा हूं वैसे करो
अगर आप
डेविएशन नहीं होगा बिलीव मी यकीन मानो
तुम्हें एकदम सॉलिड वाला हंटर बनना है कि
तुम्हें बस ये टाइम पास वाला हंटर बनना है
कि नहीं कुछ इधर जानकारी कुछ इधर जानकारी
कुछ ये ले लिया कुछ वो ले लिया खत्म नहीं
यार सॉलिड बनो ना यार जो करो मजा भी आएगा
तुम्हें तो जैसे मैं बोल रहा हूं कंटिन्यू
विट कंटिन्यू विद द फ्लो जैसे मैं बता रहा
हूं एकएक स्टेप वाइज उसको करो प्लीज एंड
जब एक दिन का मैं गैप दे रहा हूं आप लोगों
को ना हर क्लास के बाद एक दिन का कम से कम
गैप रहेगा तो वो जो गैप दे रहा हूं उसमें
जो पढ़ाया प्रीवियस सेशन में उसको कंप्लीट
करो उसको रिवाइज करो और और भी एक्सप्लोर
करो खुद से ट इज वेरी मच इंपोर्टेंट आज की
क्लास बहुत ज्यादा लंबी नहीं होगी लेकिन
इतनी वैल्युएबल है कि उसके बिना फिर आप
आगे बढ़ो
कैसे उसके हिसाब से ठीक
है जान दे देंगे सर आपके लिए अरे भाई जान
नहीं देना है भाई जान थोड़ी ना चाहिए मुझे
मुझे जान क्यों चाहिए आपकी यार ह है
चलो ओके तो चलिए तो ये टास्क जिनका बचा
हुआ है सभी कंप्लीट कर लेना है नेक्स्ट
क्लास के पहले अगर आपका कंप्लीट नहीं हुआ
तो समझो कि यू आर नॉट अ रिस्पांसिबल पर्सन
नॉट अ सिंसियर पर्सन फॉर बक बाउ ठीक है तो
इसको आपको पूरा कंप्लीट करना है ओके
दैट्ची इंपोर्टेंट चलिए अब आते हैं हम
अपने अ एक सेटअप के ऊपर जब हम बग बाउंट कर
रहे होंगे तो हमें रिक्वायरमेंट होगी v
एमवेयर की हमें रिक्वायरमेंट होगी वीए वेर
या वर्चुअल बॉक्स की ठीक है दोनों में से
कोई सा भी यूज़ कीजिएगा हमें रिक्वायरमेंट
होगी उसके अंदर काली
करने वाले हैं उन चीजों में से दो चीजें
आज मैं आपको बताने वाला हूं पहला है
मेटास्प्लोइटेबल
एंड दूसरा है
ओस ब्रोकन वेब एप्लीकेशन प्रोजेक्ट बी वेप
आप बोल सकते हो ठीक है यह दो चीजें इन
दोनों का हम यूज करने वाले हैं बहुत काम
आएगा क्योंकि हम ऐसा अप्रोच लेकर चलने
वाले हैं कि लैब प्लस लाइव टारगेट्स दोनों
हम लैब पे भी करेंगे हैंडसन करने के लिए
लाइव टारगेट पर भी करेंगे क्यों लैब क्यों
इंपॉर्टेंट है मुझे बताइए आप में से किसी
को पता है कि लैब इज इंपोर्टेंट और नॉट
मुझे आप मुझे इसी से आपके माइंडसेट का
मुझे पता चल जाएगा मुझे आप मुझे आंसर
कीजिए रियल टारगेट पर तो करेंगे बट लैब
इंपॉर्टेंट है कि नहीं लैब सॉल्व करना
मुझे आप बता दीजिए जरा एक बार सभी लोग
बताइए अपने अपने व्यूज बताइए एकदम बिंदास
जो आपके मन में आता है व बताइए मुझे चैट
में जल्दी से बताइए फटाफट हरी अप
फास्ट
फर्स्ट
डू मुझे बताइए एंड आई एम सीइंग योर
चैट देन आई विल
कंटिन्यू देन आई विल मूव फॉरवर्ड मुझे बता
द जल्दी
से चलिए अच्छी बात है
बढ़िया बढ़िया बहुत बढ़िया काफी लोगों ने
बोला बट कुछ लोग में ऐसे भी बोल रहे हैं
कि थरी से ज्यादा प्रैक्टिकल अच्छा है यह
लोग वही है जिनको कुछ नहीं आता है य यकीन
मानो एक बंदे ने बोला अमन मौर्य यह बोल
रहे हैं प्रैक्टिकल इज बेटर देन थरी अमन
भाई साहब मैं सच बता रहा हूं आपसे कोई
पर्सनल मेरी वो ग्रजेस नहीं है कुछ भी
नहीं है बट यू डोंट नो एनीथिंग बिलीव मी
एंड आपको कुछ कुछ आईडिया लगेगा भी नहीं
आने वाले टाइम में क्यों बोल रहा हूं मैं
क्योंकि यही है यही रियलिटी है जहां सिर्फ
प्रैक्टिकल प्रैक्टिकल देख रहे हो
प्रैक्टिकल पे लोग आपको बेवकूफ बना रहे
हैं थेरी का पता ही नहीं है
भाई सच में कुछ नहीं पता यार तो आप थेरी
एंड प्रैक्टिकल हमारा अप्रोच थोरी से
कांसेप्ट क्लियर प्रैक्टिकल लैब्स ये सबको
लेकर चलेंगे लाइव टारगेट्स को भी लेकर
चलेंगे सब करेंगे चलिए अब आते हैं अब यहां
से मैं आपको बोलूंगा आप में से सभी लोगों
को क्या करना है पहला पहला हम क्या करने
वाले हैं पहला हम ओस का एक प्रोजेक्ट है
उसको हम कन्फर करने वाले उसका नाम है ओस
बीडब्ल्यू ए प आपको यह सर्च करना है ग
में ठीक है
google2 सर्स फनेट इस वेबसाइट पे आपको यह
रिजल्ट मिलेगा आपको इस पर जाना है जाने के
बाद आपको यहां पर इसके डाउनलोड का ऑप्शन
मिलेगा ओस ब्रोकन वेब एप्लीकेशन प्रोजेक्ट
अब यह क्या है यह जो टूल मान लो यह जो टूल
है या प्रोजेक्ट हैय एक ऐसा टूल है जो
बेसिकली ऐसे
एप्लीकेशंस को इंक्लूड करके रखता है अपने
अंदर कंडक्ट करता है अपने अंदर जो कि
वल्नरेबल है इंटेंशनली वल्नरेबल है मान
सकते हो एंड उसको आप प्रैक्टिस के लिए यूज
कर सकते हो अब होता क्या है जैसे तुम अब
एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन की प्रैक्टिस कर रहे हो
एक्सेसेस की प्रैक्टिस कर रहे हो जब तुम
रियल टारगेट पे करोगे ना तो तुम्हें 1
मिनट के अंदर वैलिड बग नहीं मिलेगा कि
तुम्हें एक्सेसेस मिल गया चलो रिपोर्ट
किया पैसे आ गए नहीं मिलेगा कभी नहीं
मिलेगा उसमें टाइम लगेगा इट विल टेक टाइम
इट विल टेक सम अ पे इट विल टेक अ लॉट ऑफ
पेशेंस ऑफ
योर्स काफी सारी चीजें लगेंगी बट लैब्स
में क्या होता है आपको वही चीजें तुरंत
आपको सामने दिख जाती है एग्जीक्यूट हो
जाती है तो आपको एक मोटिवेशन मिलता है यू
गट मोटिवेशन कि हां भैया कर सकते हैं
बिल्कुल कर सकते हैं तो इसको आपको डाउनलोड
कर लेना है डाउनलोड पर क्लिक करोगे 1.7gb
के आसपास का होगा मेरे ख्याल से आपका
डाउनलोड हो जाएगा डाउनलोड होने के बाद
कैसा दिखेगा मैं आपको बता देता
हूं जब यह डाउनलोड हो जाएगा तो आपको यहां
पर मैं यह ऑलरेडी डाउनलोड कर चुका हूं मैं
इसका थोड़ा सा साइज इंक्रीज कर देता हूं
यह इस तरीके से दिखेगा ओप ब्रोकन वेब
एप्लीकेशन इस तरीके से दिखेगा ठीक है अब
इसको ये अनजिप किया हुआ है ये जिप किया
हुआ है सॉरी इसको क्या करना है आपको अनजिप
कर लेना है कैसे राइट क्लिक करना है इस पे
ठीक है एंड इसको कर देना
है एक्सट्रैक्ट ऑल एंड इसको कर देना है
एक्सट्रैक्ट यह क्या करेगा इसको अनजिप कर
देगा ठीक है थोड़ी बड़ी साइज है फाइल की
तो थोड़ा टाइम लगेगा आपको अनजिप होने में
अनजिप होके आपके सामने इसकी फोल्डर आ
जाएगी अब इसको हम
कॉन्फिन फिगर करेंगे अपने वर्चुअल मशीन
में क्यों करेंगे क्योंकि आपको एक बहुत
शानदार चीज दिखाऊंगा एंड द एंड आपको बहुत
अच्छी चीज एक देखने को मिलेगी इसलिए कर
रहे हैं ठीक है तो लेट इट अनजिप अब ये विज
वाला अनजिप कर रहा है खुद ही एक्सट्रैक्ट
कर रहा है तो थोड़ा टाइम लग रहा है सेजीप
वगैरह सॉफ्टवेयर होगी आपकी उससे साथ
कीजिएगा थोड़ा इसे फास्ट हो जाता है
यूजुअली ठीक है तो वो फास्ट आपका अंजीप कर
देगा फिलहाल भी वैसे भी हो चुका है
ऑलमोस्ट आधे से ज्यादा हो चुका है कॉपी कर
रहे हैं बाकी भी हो जाएंगे ठीक है
चलिए स्टडी नोट्स स्टडी नोट्स खुद ही
बनाना है भैया स्टडी नोट्स वही स्पून
फीडिंग वाली काम नहीं करनी है ना 102 लोग
हैं 64 लाइक्स ओनली मैं तो नहीं बोलूंगा
लाइक्स के लिए खुद ही करना है
आपको बिल्कुल मैं नोट्स नहीं प्रोवाइड
करता भैया किसी भी तरीके से मैं स्पून
फीडिंग वाला काम नहीं करता वह काम आपको
नहीं वह काम नहीं कर सकता मैं कि चम्मच से
लाकर और खाना खिला दो आपको वो खुद ही करनी
है आपको ज्यादा नॉलेज होगा उससे याद
रखिएगा ठीक है चलिए काफी का लोग आप में से
कोई लोग इसको डाउनलोड कर रहे हैं अभी
करेंटली आप लोग में से कितने लोग इसको
डाउनलोड अभी कर रहे हैं अभी तो वही कर रहे
होंगे जिनका इंटरनेट कनेक्शन अच्छा होगा
मतलब या तो अनलिमिटेड इंटरनेट होगी फास्ट
इंटरनेट होगी वही करेंगे बाकी लोग जिनका
पर डे वाला डटा है वो नहीं करेंगे मुझे
पता है ठीक है सो इट्स गेटिंग
डिस्ट्रैक्टेड
धन्यवाद चलिए ऑलमोस्ट हो चुका है बस एक
मिनट लगेगा और हो जाएगा ये एक्सट्रैक्ट
देन वी विल मूव
फॉरवर्ड
कर देंगे कर देंगे टेंशन मत लो
ऑर्बिट करेंगे करेंगे जब हम उस पर आएंगे
तो सब कुछ करेंगे स्लो स्लो एंड आराम से
जाइए प्लीज डोंट
स्पैम कर रहे हैं काफी लोग चलिए तो यहां
पर एक्सट्रैक्ट होके आ चुका है मैं आपको
दिखा देता हूं यह हमारा एक फोल्डर बनके आ
गया उस ब्रोकन वेब प का इस तरीके की इसमें
सारी फाइल्स आपको मिल चुकी है अब इन सारी
फाइल्स देखो यह सारी फाइल्स यह सारी
फाइल्स आ गई इन सारी फाइल्स में तुम एक
चीज देख देखोगे तो यह है एक्सटेंशन जो
तुमको दिख रही होंगी यहां पेय एक्सटेंशन
दिख रही है सबको अगर किसी के एक्सटेंशन
नहीं दिख रहा ना तो यह व्यू पर चले जाना
शो पे चले जाना एंड यहां पे फाइल नेम
एक्सटेंशंस पर टैप कर देना आपके भी
एक्सटेंशंस दिखने लगेंगे अगर बाय डिफॉल्ट
ऑन नहीं है तो तो यहां पे भ आपको
एक्सटेंशन दिख रहे हैं इन सारे एक्सटेंशन
में एक थोड़ा डिफरेंट काइंड ऑफ एक्सटेंशन
है और वो है v
ए यह एक्सटेंशन जो है यह है वर्चुअल मशीन
की कॉन्फिन फाइल क्या है वर्चुअल मशीन की
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल जब आप इस पे प्रॉपर्टीज
पे आएंगे तो आपको यहां पे दिखेगा दिस फाइल
इज़ अ टाइप ऑफ फाइल ऑफ वर्चुअल मशीन
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन वीएम वेर कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल
ठीक है इसका मतलब क्या है इसके अंदर एक
पूरी कॉन्फ़िगरेशन लिखी हुई है एंड उसी
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन के अकॉर्डिंग यह वीएम वेर
में काम करेगा तो भैया अब हम इसको इंस्टॉल
करेंगे कैसे करेंगे बहुत आसान है बहुत
सिंपल है लेकिन स्टेप वाइज आपको करना है
आपको v ए वेर ओपन कर लेना है कुछ इस तरीके
से काली की तरह इसमें काम नहीं करना है
आपको इंस्टॉलेशन नहीं करनी है आपको यहां
पे
[संगीत]
vmmc-sjh.nic.in यही फाइल एक सपोर्टेड
फाइल है यही फाइल क्या है सपोर्टेड फाइल
है क्यों क्योंकि यहां जो लिखा हुआ है
यहां पे ऑल सपोर्टेड फाइल अब इसमें तुम
वीएम वेयर कॉन्फिन फाइल भी सिलेक्ट कर
लोगे तो भी वीएमए तुम्हें दिखेगा जैसे
क्लिक सिलेक्ट किया ये वीएमए दिख रहा है
बट अब यहां पे आके अगर तुम ये वाली फाइल
सिलेक्ट कर लोगे ओपन वर्चुअल मशीन फॉर्मेट
जो कि आपके बेसिकली वर्चुअल बॉक्स जब आप
यूज कर रहे होगे तो उसमें आपका ये सपोर्ट
कर जाएगा तो आप जब ये करोगे तो ये गायब हो
जाएगा और या फिर आप ऑल कर दो सारे फाइल्स
आ जाएंगे तो हमें चाहिए भैया सपोर्टेड
वाले तो हम सपोर्टेड वाले ने हमने किया और
vmxnet3
फरदर हंट ऑन कर सकते हैं फरदर हंट ऑन यू
कैन डू अच्छा मुझे चलो आगे बढ़ता हूं मैं
मुझे सच सच ईमानदारी से बताओ जस्ट
ईमानदारी से आप में से कितने लोग यह जो
ब्रक जो बग बाउटी की क्लासेस चल रही है जो
वीडियोस आ रही है आपके तीन हमारी थर्ड
क्लास है बग बाउंट की एंड बग बाउंट का ही
एंड्राइड पन टेस्टिंग के दो क्लासेस हुए
हैं ईमानदारी से ऑनेस्टली बताओ मुझे एकदम
झूठ मत बोलना कितने लोग आप लोग शेयर करते
हो इन वीडियोस को अपने अपने जहां भी है
आपका सोशल प्रेजेंस या आपके कम्युनिटी
कितने लोग शेयर करते हो ईमानदारी से बता
देना मुझे यार झूठ नहीं बोलना है जितना
शेयर करते हो तोही बताना नहीं करते हो कोई
बात नहीं कोई टेंशन नहीं है तो मुझे एक ब
बता
दो हां जी व वर्चुअल बॉक्स में भी कर सकते
हो यार दिखाया तो ओवी फाइल वर्चुअल बॉक्स
के लिए कर सकते हो मुझे बता दो
जल्दी चलिए कितने लोग शेयर करते हो मुझे
एक बार जानना है यार आप में से कितने लोग
मतलब सट कर रहे हो कम से कम सपोर्ट तो कर
ही सकते हो ना इसलिए पूछा
बस बिल्कुल कर सकते हैं
थारा ओके थैंक
यू थैंक यू सो मच सभी
को जितने लोग
भी यस इनको गीक आई नो ठीक है तो जितने लोग
भी शेयर करते
हैं वाह वाटी वाले अभी नोटिफिकेशन भेजा
इतना लेट नोटिफिकेशन भेजा क्या यार ये
वाइटी वाले पागल है यार सच में ये वाइटी
वालों को कुछ पता नहीं है ये इतना लेट
नोटिफिकेशन भेजते हैं कभी-कभी तो थैंक यू
सो
मच सबको थैंक यू अमन थैंक यू नचिकेत इनको
सबको थैंक यू सभी लोग को थैंक यू जो शेयर
करते हैं क्योंकि यही मोटिवेट करेगी याद
रखिए गाइस यह मोटिवेशन बहुत जरूरी है किसी
भी ट्रेनर के लिए मोटिवेशन जरूरी बहुत
ज्यादा है सोचो एक क्लास है सोचो एक क्लास
में
100 50 बच्चे हैं टीचर आता है उसको पढ़ाता
है बहुत मजा आता है उसको बहुत एनर्जेटिक
फील होता है वही उस क्लास में जाए और वो
दो बच्चे रहे तो वो भी थोड़ा सा डाउन हो
जाएगा अरे यार क्या है यार ट्स वई ठीक है
सो प्लीज
डोंट वो आप स्पैम मत कीजिए नहीं तो टाइम
आउट में डाल दूंगा जैसे मैं अभी एक यूजर
को टाइम आउट में डाल देता हूं क्योंकि ही
इज स्पैमिंग तो मैं कुछ नहीं कर सकता सॉरी
एक्सट्रीमली सॉरी बट आप प्लीज टाइम आउट के
लिए मत कीजिए इस तरह से तो लेट्स पुट हिम
इन अ टाइम आउट अ इनको कर देते हैं 30 मिनट
के लिए टाइम आउट
पे चलिए तो अब यहां पे हमने इसको
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन को लोड कर लिया है अब हम
क्या करेंगे अगर आपको कुछ चेंज करना है तो
आप क्या कर सकते हैं आप एडिट वर्चुअल
मशीनस पे आप एडिट वर्चुअल मशीन पे जाइए
यहां पे कुछ अपग्रेड करना है आपको चेंज
करना है मेमोरी वगैरह प्रोसेसर वगैरह आप
चेंज कर सकते हैं एंड देन अ यू कैन गो विथ
योर ओन कॉन्फ़िगरेशन यहां पे एक आ रहा है
ये अपग्रेड करने का हार्डवेयर
कंपैटिबिलिटी ठीक है व कोई दिक्कत नहीं है
इसके लिए कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है ठीक है तो
दैट इट यह काम हो गया अब इसको हम ऑन
करेंगे जब हम ऑन करेंगे तो देखिए ये ऑन हो
रहा है अब यहां पे आपको एक पॉपअप आ रहा है
मान लो इस तरीके से यह पॉपअप आप क्या
कीजिएगा अगर आपको कुछ समझ में नहीं आ रहा
सीधा कॉपी एडिट प क्लिक कर दीजिए इसके लिए
आपको कोई कुछ ऐसा दिमाग नहीं लगाना है कुछ
ज्यादा सोचना नहीं है इसमें ठीक है तो
दैट्ची कुछ डी मंस जो होते हैं वह सारे
स्टार्ट हो रहे हैं आपके एंड वी विल गेट द
फाइनल स्क्रीन वेरी सून तो आपको यह काम
करना है इसको ऑन कर देना है चलिए हमने ऑन
किया इट्स गेटिंग ऑन गेटिंग ऑन गेटिंग ऑन
इनका हम यूज करेंगे याद रखिएगा जो भी मैं
बता रहा हूं वो वेस्ट नहीं जाने वाला है
आपका यूज आएगा तो जो मैं बताऊं जो मैं
करूं वो कर लेना है जो अभी कर पा रहे हैं
वो कर लीजिए जो नहीं कर पाए वो सेशन के
बाद कर सकते हैं कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है ठीक
है तो हमने क्या किया यहां पे भैया हमारी
स्क्रीन आ गई अब यहां पे क्या आ रहा है ओस
बीडब्ल्यू ए लॉगइन तो लॉगिन क्या है भाई
लॉगइन लॉगिन भी दे रखा है लॉगिन यूजर नेम
रूट है पासवर्ड इज ओ बीडल ए तो यह भी दे
रखा है तो चलिए बढ़िया है अब क्या करते
हैं लॉगइन करके देखते हैं रूट यहां एंड
पासवर्ड क्या है ओ वास्प बीडल ए तो हमने
पासवर्ड भी डाल दिया एंटर किया जैसे ही
हमने किया यहां हम लॉग इन हो चुके हैं मैं
स्क्रीन को क्लियर कर देता हूं और यहां पे
हम आईपी देख लेते हैं क्या है आईपी क्या
है हमारी 192
16.11.19
क्या है 192 16.11.19 अब ये आईपी मुझे
थोड़ी डिफरेंट क्यों मिली है मैं आपको
इसका लॉजिक भी समझा देता हूं चलिए मैं
इसको थोड़ा सा इसको अ इसकी इसको मिनिमाइज
वो करता हूं मैक्सिमाइज हटा देता हूं यहां
से एंड यहां पे इस वर्चुअल मशीन के राइट
क्लिक करो यहां पे एंड गो टू द सेटिंग्स
सेटिंग्स में जाओगे यहां पे तो यहां
नेटवर्क एडाप्टर जो है ये नेट सिलेक्टेड
है इट्स सिलेक्टेड एज नेट क्योंकि नेट है
इसलिए यहां पे नेट वाली आईपी एड्रेस यहां
पे ये कंफिल कर चुका है एंड वही आईपी ले
रहा है अगर आपको सिस्टम की आईपी को शेयर
करना है तो आपके आपके लाइक होस्ट आईपी को
तो आप ब्रिज वाले सिलेक्ट कर लीजिएगा एंड
ओके पे क्लिक कर दीजिएगा देन आपका जो यह
आईपी है ये ऑटोमेटिक स्विच हो जाएगा कहां
पे ब्रिज पे एंड यू विल गेट द ब्रिज आईपी
एड्रेस अब ये मैं आपको रीस्टार्ट करके
यहां पे दिखा देता हूं जैसे लेट्स
रीस्टार्ट दिस स बीडब्ल्यू ए एंड
रीस्टार्ट के बाद आईपी जब आप देखोगे तो ये
आईपी इस आईपी से अलाइड या इस सबनेट से
अलाइन आईपी आपको मिलेगी जो हमारी होस्ट की
है होस्ट की आईपी क्या है भैया चलिए होस्ट
की आईपी भी देख लेते हैं लेट्स ओपन होस्ट
सीएमडी यह रहा एंड आईपी कॉन्फिन जब आप
होस्ट की आईपी देखोगे तो इट्स 190 नहीं ये
नहीं है यार कौन सी है यह भी नहीं है यह
वाली 192 16629 43 तो इसकी जो आईपी आएगी ओ
की बीडल की 192 1629 तो रहेगा ही रहेगा
लास्ट का डिजिट आपका वैरी करेगा डीएचसीपी
भैया जी अपना काम करेंगे यहां डीएचसीपी
अपना काम करेगा और आपको एक आईपी प्रोवाइड
कर देगा तो हम यहां पे लॉगिन हो चुके हैं
बढ़िया नहीं लॉगिन नहीं हुए लॉगइन करेंगे
अब चलिए लेट्स लॉग इन अगेन
रूट एंड ओस बीडब्ल्यूए
दैट्ची नहीं मिला है इट माइट बी सम इशू
विथ द ब्रिज एडाप्टर तो अब चलते हैं यहां
पे सेटिंग्स में चलते हैं एंड यहां पे
देखते हैं यहां पे ब्रिज पे चल रहा है
ऑटोमेटिक ब्रिज पे यहां पे सिलेक्टेड है
अब क्या करेंगे इसमें कुछ एरर आ रही है
मान लो कुछ प्रॉब्लम आ रही है तो भैया
क्या करेंगे एक नेटवर्क एडिटर खोल लेंगे
ये वर्चुअल नेटवर्क एडिटर है ना इसको हम
खोल के देख लेते हैं क्या प्रॉब्लम आ रही
है भैया क्या इशू आ रहा है तो चलिए अब
यहां पे कर देते हैं चेंज सेटिंग्स
पे यस नाउ लेट्स सी एंड यहां पे आप देख
रहे हैं ब्रिज जो है यहां पे हमारा ऑटो
ब्रिजिंग हो रहा है ठीक है ऑटो ब्रिजिंग
के केस में कई बार इशू आ जाते हैं आपको
मैनुअली एडेप्टर सेलेक्ट करना है यहां पे
आप आइएगा यहां पे ऑटोमेटिक पे यहां पे
जाइएगा एंड अपना वायरलेस एडाप्टर सिलेक्ट
कर लीजिएगा तो कौन सा वायरलेस एडाप्टर
मेरा ये
int64 मेगा हज वाली मैंने इसको सेलेक्ट कर
लिया एंड यहां पे इसको अप्लाई कर दिया
अप्लाई करके ये नेटवर्क कॉन्फिन कर देगा
सब कुछ ओके एंड यहां पे हमने ओके कर लिया
सब कुछ हो गया डन अब देखते हैं यहां पे अ
सर्विस नेटवर्क मैनेजर रीस्टार्ट लेट्स सी
ओके ओके ओके ओके ओके ओके
ओके ओके सो एक काम करते हैं आईएफ
कॉन्फिनेट से नो एंड लेट्स रिबूट इसको फिर
से रिबूट कर देते हैं एंड नाउ इट शुड इट
शुड गेट द लाइक आईपी एड्रेस आईपी एड्रेस
उसको जो है हमारी मिल जानी चाहिए क्योंकि
हमारा ब्रिज कनेक्टिविटी जो हमारे हमने
मैप कर दिया हमने हमारे एडाप्टर पे जो
हमारा इंटरनल एडॉप्टर है सो लेट्स सी क्या
होता है चलिए देखते हैं बिल्कुल बिल्कुल
वैसा ही है बट यह थोड़ा डिफरेंट है मैं
आपको दिखाता हूं कैसे डिफरेंट है लेट्स सी
फर्स्ट लेट इट गेट द आईपी एड्रेस आई थिंक
इस बार आईपी एड्रेस मिल जानी चाहिए मेरे
ख्याल से या इस बार आईपी एड्रेस मिलेगी
भैया चलिए रूट से लॉगिन करते हैं ओस
बीडब्ल्यू ए करते हैं एंड लॉगिन हो चुके
हैं अब आईएफ
कॉन्फिडे भैया हो जा चलो अब देखो हमें
आईपी एड्रेस मिल गई 19216 29.6 अब हम
बढ़िया अब हम अपने होस्ट मशीन को पिंग कर
लेते हैं कनेक्ट है क्या पिंग 192 ओ सॉरी
192.168 29.4 6 आईपी थी हमारी होस्ट आईपी
की होस्ट की होस्ट की 4 हां होस्ट
डेस्टिनेशन अनरीचेबल आ रहा है 46 नहीं थी
क्या हमारी आईपी भाई क्या थी चलो देख लेते
हैं आईपी
कॉन्फिनेट आईपी डाला 43 डालते हैं एंड पिन
करते हैं एंड इट्स एंड इट शुड बी
पिी लेट्स सी व्हाट इज
हैपनिंग 18216 29
43 ओके दो सो अब ये पिं अगर नहीं हो रहा
है देन व्हाट कैन बी अ द इशू क्या इशू हो
सकता है मुझे आप लोग बताइए जल्दी जल्दी
बताइए मुझे आप लोग अब मैं इससे क्या करता
हूं इससे इसको पिंग करता हूं मैं अपने
होस्ट से चलो होस्ट से पिंग करते हैं पिंग
192.168
2986 ठीक है 86 है ना हमारा लेट्स सी एंड
सी ये पिंग हो रहा है हमारा होस्ट पिंग कर
पा रहा है 86 को अब हमारी आईपी जो है आईपी
कॉन्फिन गेटिंग पिंग सो 189 43 सेम है
चलिए
स्टार्ट 2943 लेट्स पिंक अब बताइए मुझे कि
व्हाई इट इज नॉट पिंकिंग लेट मी नो लेट मी
टेल लेट मी टेल यू व्हाई इट इज नॉट
पिंकिंग अब यहां पे हमारा होस्ट पिं कर
रहा है हमारे मशीन को यह नहीं पिं कर पा
रहा है एंड इसका एक मेजर रीजन हो सकता है
आपका
फायरवॉल आपका फायरवॉल क्या रीजन हो सकता
है आपका फायरवॉल क्योंकि क्योंकि यहां ओस
की जो मशीन है यह तो वल्नरेबल मशीन है
इसका क्या फायरवॉल क्या फायरवॉल इसको तो
सब पिंग करेंगे लेकिन यह पिंग नहीं कर पा
रहा मशीन को क्योंकि आपका फायरवॉल मे बी
इसको रोक रहा है इट्स स्टॉपिंग तो अब क्या
करते हैं लेट्स ट्राई दैट आल्सो लेट्स
टर्न ऑफ आवर फायरवॉल लेट्स ओपन विंडोज
फायरवॉल विंडोज फायरवॉल चलिए विंडोज
फायरवॉल को ओपन कर लेते
हैं यहां पे एंड टर्न विंडोज फायरवॉल को
एक बार ऑफ करके देख लेते हैं लेट्स सी
व्हाट इज हैपनिंग या फिर हम इसको
एक्सप्लीसिटली अलाउ भी कर सकते हैं अलाउ
डिस अलाउ में जाके वो अलग बात है फिलहाल
केलिए हमने इसको क्या किया बंद किया एंड
लेट्स पिंग नाउ एंड सी इट्स पिंगिफोव्यू
टू द फायर वल रूल्स ड्यू टू द नेटवर्क
कॉन्फिन ऑन दैट पर्टिकुलर डेस्टिनेशन मशीन
तो यह आ रहा है समझ में आ रहा है इतना समझ
में यह कांसेप्ट समझ में आ गया क्योंकि
इसलिए मैंने इसको बताया आपको ताकि थोड़ा
यह भी आपको समझ में आ जाए ठीक
है ठीक है एवन
गट ओके मुझे बताइए थैंक यू फैक्ट नंबर वन
जसदीप
सिंह या एब्सलूट करेक्ट
सकम ओके सो लाउ फरल वर गेटिंग द रिपस समझ
में आ
गया या
ओके
ग्रेट ग्रेट ग्रेट
ग्रेट सर मेरा प्राइमरी ओस लिनिक्स है तो
मैं कैसे करूं लिनिक्स में इंस्टॉल कर
सकते हो यार यू कन इंस्टॉल फॉर द लिनिक्स
आल्सो ड डोंट वरी अबाउट ट ठीक है कर सकते
हो सर मैं भी आपको पिंग कर रहा हूं हे
भगवान मुझे पिंग करोगे तो कैसे होगा यार
आई एम इन अ वन दिस इ पिंग द मशीन वी आर
पिंग मशीन लन लन और वन का कांसेप्ट है
भैया आप मुझे पिंग नहीं कर सकते हो याद
रखिएगा यू कांट पिंग माय प्राइवेट आईपी ये
लन में है तो पिंग हो रहा है भाई समझ में
आ रहा है एक गेटवे के थ्रू ही आप न में
पिंग कर सकते हो विदाउट गेटवे यू कैन नॉट
पिंग अनदर कंप्यूटर ऑन ऑन अ नेटवर्क ठीक
है गेटवे चाहिए जैसे
मुझे क्या है ग इसी से पता चलेगा यह
क्वेश्चन सबसे है यह बहुत ट्रिकी क्वेश्चन
है मुझे बताइए व्ट इज ग ग क्या है नाम पर
मत जाना ग क्या है मुझे
बताइए चलो बताओ मुझे ग क्या
है देखते हैं कितने लोगों का क्या आंसर
आता
है अरे वन कहां से है भाई ग न ग वन है ह
है क्या है सर्च इंजन गुड गुड गुड गुड
सर्च
इंजन ओके सर्च इंजन सर्च इंजन सर्वर है ग
गुड देखो गल जो है ना
भाई ग गल भी आपका यह जो आपको दिख रहा है ग
छोड़ो यहां क्या दिख रहा है यहां देख लो ग
यह जो आपको दिख रहा है यह ग भी एक
कंप्यूटर ही है जैसे मैं अपना कंप्यूटर
यूज कर रहा हूं ना यह भी एक कंप्यूटर है
यार सर्वर है सर्वर को कंप्यूटर ही बोलते
हैं सर्वर सर्वर कुछ नहीं होता सर्वर ही
कंप्यूटर है अब तुम इसी कंप्यूटर को पिंग
कर सकते हो तुम पिंग करोगे
पिंग
रिक्वेस्ट वन में कर पा रहे हो ये गेटवे
के थ्रू गेटवे नहीं है तो आपके कंप्यूटर
तक कोई और बाहर से पहुंच ही नहीं सकता
जैसे आपके घर में गेटवे क्या होता है
बताइए मुझे आपके लोकल नेटवर्क कॉन्फिन जो
करते हो अपने घर वगैरह में या ऑफिस में
छोटा-मोटा उसमें गेटवे किसको बोलते हैं
जरा बताइए मुझे व्हाट इज द
गेटवे बताइए जरा गेटवे क्या होता
है गेटवे किसको बोलते हैं बोलिए जरा चलिए
इनको भी टाइम आउट प रख देते हैं 30 मिनट
के लिए अगले 30 मिनट के लिए तनिश रावत जी
है टाइम आउट पर ड्यू टू द स्पैम तो कोई
फायदा नहीं है आप फिर वो टाइम आउट पर चले
जाएंगे तो चैट भी नहीं कर पाएंगे चलिए
मुझे
बताइए गेटवे क्या
है सभी लोग आंसर करो यहां पर दो चार लोग
आंसर कर रहे बाकी लोग क्या कर रहे हो बताओ
यार बाकी लोग मतलब अरे यार चिप्स खा रहे
हो क्या क्या खा रहे हो
यार ओके राउटर राउटर राउटर काफी लोग राउटर
गुड गुड गुड यस गेटवे राउटर ट उसके थ्रू
ही आप कुछ कनेक्टिविटी कर पाओगे नहीं तो
नहीं कर पाओगे ठीक है तो गेटवे आपका होना
जरूरी है तो चलिए हम यहां पे आ चुके हैं
ओप बवप के अंदर यहां पे हम लॉगइन हो चुके
हैं एंड यहां पे वी आर सक्सेसफुली लॉग इन
एंड आप अगर चेक करेंगे तो आपकी आईपी है 86
अब गाइ अगर आप इस आईपी को ब्राउजर में ओपन
करोगे ना लेट्स गो टू द ब्राउजर एंड लेट्स
ओपन दिस आईपी
192.168
29.8 यही है ना लेट्स ओपन एंड सी व्हाट यू
गेटिंग देखो क्या आपको मिल रहा है आपको एक
वेबसाइट मिल रही है एक वेब पेज मिल रहा है
भैया हम तो आईपी पे आए थे यह वेब पेज कैसे
मिल गया इससे क्या प्रूफ होता है व्हाट इज
गेटिंग प्रूफ फ्रॉम दिस कांसेप्ट कांसेप्ट
सीखना बहुत जरूरी है हर बात में कांसेप्ट
है याद रखना बग बाउटी में भी कांसेप्ट बग
बांटी के हर एक चीज में कांसेप्ट इससे
क्या कांसेप्ट है कि आईपी एड्रेस प ही वेब
पेज होस्ट होती है डोमेन तो हमें याद करने
के लिए दिया जाता है अब तुम आईपी थोड़ी ना
याद करोगे कि भैया यह वो वो डोमेन तो हमें
याद करने के लिए दिया जाता है आईपी पे
सारा गेम है अब इस आईपी पे एक डोमेन है एक
पेज रखा हुआ है क्योंकि यह लोकल एरिया
नेटवर्क में आपका यह पेज चल रहा है लान
में चल रहा है तो आपके इस आईपी पे यह पेज
कंफर हो गई जैसे ही आपने मशीन को कन्फर
करा अब इस पे है वोह
सारे सारे एप्लीकेशंस जिन पर आप प्रैक्टिस
कर सकते हो
यू कैन प्रैक्टिस
ऑन ठीक है तो यह बीओस बीडल एक वल्नरेबल
वर्चुअल मशीन था जिसमें आपको अलग-अलग
एप्लीकेशंस जैसे कि यह ट्रेनिंग
एप्लीकेशंस हैं इसमें यह आपको ट्रेनिंग
एप्लीकेशंस आपको सारे मिल जाएंगे जिनके भी
पॉपुलर नाम आपने सुने होंगे आज तक जैसे
आपने बवप सुना होगा यू वांट टू लंच बवप
जस्ट क्लिक ऑन दस एंड बवप विल बी लॉन्च्ड
यू वांट टू ओपन अ डीवीडब्ल्यू डैम
वल्नरेबल वेब एप्लीकेशन जस्ट क्लिक ऑन
हियर एंड इट विल बी लॉन्च्ड यू वांट टू
ओपन ओ मटली डे टू आप इस पे ओपन कीजिए एंड
ये ओपन हो जाएगा यू वांट टू लच ओ web.net
वाली तो आप इसको ओपन कीजिए एंड इट विल गेट
लॉन्च्ड यू वांट टू ओपन वेब गट ये शायद
पीएचपी वाली होगी तो ये इस तरह से ओपन हो
जाएगी रेल्स गोट ये ओपन हो जाएगी कोन
इंजेक्शन कोड इंजेक्शन रेबो आप ये कीजिए
आप यह आपका ओपन हो जाएगा तो सारे जो आपके
प्रैक्टिस वाली मशीन है एक जगह ही मिल
जाएगी ओप बी वप के अंदर में आपको अलग से
डीवीडब्ल्यू इंस्टॉल नहीं करना है बवप
इंस्टॉल नहीं करना है मटली डे को नहीं
डालना कुछ नहीं करना भैया सब यहीं पे मिल
रहा है गॉट
इट गॉट इट सबको समझ में आ गया यह मस्त चीज
है ना है कि नहीं मस् चीज सारी चीजें एक
ही जगह देख लो
भाई करेक्ट ठीक है ना एवरीवन यह सारे देखो
यहां सारे दी हुई है ये
देखो ये देख रहे हो a1 से लेके a10 तक
हालांकि इन्होंने अपडेट नहीं किया 2021 के
अकॉर्डिंग बट स्टिल ठीक है चलेगा काम अभी
चलेगा ठीक
है ओके ग इट अरे आ जाओ आ जाओ अभी देखते
जाओ देखते जाओ अभी नीचे आते हैं नीचे आते
हैं अभी सब देखते जाओ देखते जाओ यहां पे आ
जाओ एंड यहां पे नीचे जब आओगे नीचे जब
आओगे तो यहां पे रियलिस्टिक इंटेंशनली
वल्नरेबल वेब एप्लीकेशंस आपको मिलेंगे कुछ
ऐसे वेब एप्लीकेशंस जो रियलिस्टिक वेब
एप्लीकेशंस आपको एंड इंटेंशनली वल्नरेबल
है वो आपको यहां पे मिलेंगे सारे यहां पे
मिलेंगे ठीक है यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं
इसमें आपका
googlegroups.com ली इस मशीन के अंदर सारा
कुछ स्टार्ट हो जाएगा जिस पे आप प्रैक्टिस
कर सकते हो तो चलिए यह सारे तो चलो
स्टार्ट हो रहे हैं इसको तो अभी फिलहाल
बंद कर देते हैं इसके अलावा नीचे आओगे आप
तो ओल्ड वल्नरेबल वर्जंस जो है ना वो आपको
मिल जाएंगे जो भी ओल्ड वल्नरेबल वर्जंस है
ना पॉपुलर एप्लीकेशंस के या सीएमएसएस के
वो मिल जाएंगे जैसे वर्डप्रेस का मिल
जाएगा गेट बु का मिलेगा और या का मिलेगा
गैलरी टू का मिलेगा जूमला का मिलेगा ये
सारे मिल रहे हैं टकी वकी सब मिल रहे हैं
सब आपको मिल जाएंगे जैसे वर्डप्रेस पे
आपको प्रैक्टिस करनी है य गट अ वर्डप्रेस
साइट हियर नाउ कम एंड प्रैक्टिस अब ये
कैसे क्या है वो सब मैं बताऊंगा टेंशन मत
लो हम इस पर प्रैक्टिकल भी करने करेंगे
कोई टेंशन नहीं है बहुत सारी क्लासेस अभी
बाकी है यार करनी है अभी तो बहुत कुछ करना
है नीचे आओगे एप्लीकेशंस फॉर टेस्टिंग
टूल्स टूल्स को टेस्ट करने के लिए ये
एप्लीकेशंस है जहां पे आप आके टूल्स को
टेस्ट कर सकते हो ठीक है आप टूल्स को क्या
कर सकते हो टेस्ट कर सकते हो नीचे आप आओगे
यहां पे तो यहां पे डेमोंस्ट्रेट पेजेस या
स्मॉल एप्लीकेशंस है जो आपको यहां पे मिल
जाती है एंड यहां पे एक डेमोंस्ट्रेट
एप्लीकेशन है आपको ये मिल जाता है एक
एप्लीकेशन है बेसिकली जो आपको यहां पे ये
मिल जाता है ठीक है तो ये सारी चीजें आपको
एक जगह मिल जाती है एंड ये सारे काम आपके
आते हैं बहुत सारे लोग बहुत सारी तरह तरह
की चीजें आपके यूज करते हैं इसमें बट
इसमें आपको ये नहीं बोलूंगा कि आप सब कुछ
करने लगो नहीं आपके काम की सारी नहीं है
जो जो मैं आपको बताता चलूंगा समझाता
चलूंगा आप वो प्रैक्टिसेस करते चलना
दैट्ची ओपन कर चुके हो अभी ही जिन्होंने
नहीं किया वो बाद में कर लेना एज अ टास्क
रहेगा वो आपका ये आपका नेक्स्ट क्लास से
पहले कर लेना बट अभी कितने लोगों ने कर
लिया मुझे बताइए जरा लेट मी
सी कितने लोगों ने कर लिया ओ आज तो यार
100 लाइक सभी हो गए हैं क्या बात है
धन्यवाद भाई सभी को काफी लोगों ने कर लिया
होगा मेरे ख्याल से सैयद
सैयद ठीक है सैयद अकरी बली कर लिया
उन्होंने
प्रोग्रामिंग जावास्क्रिप्ट कुछ नहीं
चाहिए इस बक बाउटी कोर्स के लिए किसी भी
चीज की नॉलेज नहीं है चाहिए आपको अभी इस
कोर्स के लिए जहां अगर रिक्वायरमेंट
पड़ेगी आपको मैं पहले ही बता दूंगा टेंशन
नहीं लेनी है बस करते
जाइए
ओके बेटा स्टेबल हम अलग से
करेंगे
ओके बहुत लोग कर रहे हैं लिमिटेड डाटा है
जो नहीं कर रहे कोई बात नहीं बाद में कर
लीजिएगा कोई टेंशन नहीं है ठीक है अब ये
तो आपका ओस बी वेब आपका यहां पे कंफिल हो
गया या सॉरी हां ओ का आपका ब्रोकन वेब
एप्लीकेशन आपका यहां पे आ चुका है ओस
बीडब्ल्यूए जिसको आप बोल रहे हैं अब ओस
बीडब्ल्यूए जब आ गया तो अब यहां पे इनके
हम प्रैक्टिसेस भी करेंगे आने वाले
क्लासेस में क्योंकि अब जो क्लासेस आएंगे
या आज की भी क्लास अब जो भी आएगा वो
प्रैक्टिकल ही आएगा थरी थोड़ा बहुत होगा
कांसेप्ट कांसेप्ट वाइज आपको थेरी बताए
जाएंगे बिकॉज बज मैं बिलीव करता हूं इफ यू
डोंट नो थिरी यू हैव नो राइट टू डू द
प्रैक्टिकल कोई आपका राइट नहीं आप कर ले
वो अलग बात है जबरदस्ती वाला काम बट आपका
राइट नहीं बनता है वहां प्रैक्टिकल करने
का अगर आपका कांसेप्ट सही नहीं है तो
लॉजिक आपको लगाने नहीं आता आप अपना दिमाग
नहीं लगा पा रहे हो तो ट्स इट यही मेरा
स्टाइल है एंड इसी तरीके से आपको मैं
पढ़ाऊंगा भी सिखाऊंगा भी एंड आपको पढ़ना
है सीखना है वैसे ही
ओके ग्रेट चलिए तो ये सारी चीजें आपको ये
आपको करके लाना है अब देखो इसी के लिए अब
अलग-अलग तुम इंस्टॉल करो ना जब अलग-अलग
एप्लीकेशन इंस्टॉल करोगे जैसे कई लोग क्या
करते हैं मैं आपको एक चीज बताता हूं कई
आपको कई लोग क्या करते हैं डैम वल्नरेबल
वेब एप्लीकेशन को अलग इंस्टॉल करते हैं ओस
मटली डे को अलग से कर लिया बवप को अलग से
कर लिया ठीक है ना वेब गोट अलग से कर लिया
या जो भी है बट यहां पे जो जो अलग से
अवेलेबल है वो अलग से कई बार कई लोग कर
लेते हैं यहां पे आपको एक साथ ही मिल जा
रहा है पहली बात दूसरी बात आप अलग से करते
हो जम सर्वर वगैरह का कई बार यूज करना पड़
जाता है आपको कई सारा लोड पड़ जाता है कई
सारा जैम के साथ इश्यूज आ जाते ते हैं तो
वह आप यहां से बच जाते हो दैट्ची है तो यह
आपको कर लेना है जिन्होंने अभी नहीं करा
उनके लिए यह टास्क है कि दे हैव टू
कंप्लीट इट दे हैव टू कंफिल डाउनलोड कर
लेना ओस ब्रोकन वेब एप्लीकेशन प्रोजेक्ट
को सोर्स फोथ से उसके बाद उसको अनजिप कर
लेना है वीएम वेर में आके जैसा मैंने आपको
बताया यहां से आपको फाइल में जाके ओपन
करना है या ओपन अ वर्चुअल मशीन पे जाना है
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल
vmxnet3 कन्फेशन हो जाएगा वीएम वेर में
आपका वर्चुअल मशीन जो है ओस पॉली वो आ
जाएगी आईपी मिल जाएगी आपको एंड आईपी मिल
जाएगी तो आप उसको वेब पे एक्सेस कर सकते
हैं इन मशीनस को इस तरीके से एक्सेस कर
सकते हैं
दैट्ची द कोर्स तो भाई आप ऐप में जाके
वहां कोर्स बाय करने की कोशिश करो हमारा
जो फनि अकेडमी ए एप्लीकेशन है उसको
इंस्टॉल करके वहां ट्राई मारो अगर वहां से
कर सकते हो तो अच्छी बात है अगर नहीं कर
पा रहे हो तो फिर मैं ज्यादा कुछ इसमें
नहीं कर सकता एक्सट्रीमली सॉरी अभी हमारे
पास ज्यादा ऑप्शंस नहीं है बट जल्दी ही
हमारे पास सारे ऑप्शंस आ जाएंगे
यूटिलाइज हम करने वाले हैं एंड दैट इज नोन
एज इसको मैं फिलहाल बंद कर देता हूं इसकी
रिक्वायरमेंट अभी नहीं है जब हम
प्रैक्टिकल इसका परफॉर्म कर रहे होंगे ना
अ जब बहुत सारी चीजें करेंगे तब हम इसको
यूज़ करेंगे नेक्स्ट पार्ट इज नेक्स्ट
अ कहां गया हमारा नेक्स्ट
इज मेटा एक्सप्लोइटेबल मेटा एक्सप्लोइटेबल
इसको करना है डाउनलोड ऐसे सर्च करना है
आपको यहां पे मेटा स् पलटेबल डाउनलोड का
ऑप्शन आ जाएगा या फिर आप मेट स् पलटेबल टू
डाउनलोड ऑप्शन पे जाइए ये भी आपको फिलहाल
वहीं पे लेके जाएगा तो आप उस पे जाइए एंड
जब जाएंगे यहां पे देखिए यहां पे मेट
पलटेबल डाउनलोड टू का आ गया अब यहां पे
अवेलेबिलिटी कहां पे है भैया सोर्स फोज पे
है और इस पे है दोनों पे है तो सोर्स फोज
वाले पे चल जाते हैं यहां पे आप चले आइएगा
सोर्स फोर्ज के वेबसाइट पे आ जाइएगा एंड
इसको डाउनलोड कर लीजिएगा 800 एब के आसपास
की ये होगी शायद जहां तक मुझे ध्यान आ रहा
है अप्रॉक्स इसको आप डाउनलोड कर लीजिएगा
एंड डाउनलोड करने के बाद अगेन आपको कुछ इस
तरीके से यह फोल्डर आपको मिल जाएगी मेटा
स्पल टे
टू की इसको भी आपको क्या करना है राइट
क्लिक करना है इस बार मैं सेवन जिप का यूज
करूंगा जो कि मेरे पास नहीं है अब से जिप
को यूज करने के लिए मुझे से जिप चाहिए तो
बट ठीक है इस बार अभी से इसी से इस हम चला
लेते हैं विंडोज के एक्सट्रैक्टर को यूज
कर लेते हैं और इसको कर देते हैं
एक्सट्रैक्ट क्योंकि ये बहुत ज्यादा बड़ा
नहीं है तो ये जल्दी एक्सट्रैक्ट हो जाएगा
देन द ओ वेस्प सो यू शुड एक्सट्रैक्ट दिस
एक्सट्रैक्ट करने के बाद इसको कंफिट
करेंगे अब ये जो मेटास्प्लोइटेबल है ना
इसको कंफ्यूज मत करना मेटास्प्लोइटेबल
से अच्छा मुझे आप मुझे एक बात बताओ आपसे
क्वेश्चन है मेटा एक्सप्लोइट फ्रेमवर्क या
मेटा एक्सप्लोइटेबल यह दोनों सेम है या
डिफरेंट है मुझे इतना बताइए आप लोग मेटा
स्प्लटर वर्क या मेटा स्प्लाइंड यह
मेटास्प्लोइटेबल ये दोनों डिफरेंट चीज है
या सेम है लेट मी
नो लेट मी
नो
प्लीज लेट मी
नो मुझे
बताइए मुझे बताइए मेटा
स्पल एंड मेटास्प्लोइटेबल
यह दोनों सेम है या डिफरेंट
है डिफरेंट डिफरेंट डिफरेंट
डिफरेंट सय ने बोला एक ने बोला सेम नो
आईडिया
ओके एक टूल है और एक वल्नरेबल मशीन अच्छा
ठीक
है ग्रेट
चलिए
बढ़िया चलिए एक सैयद सैयद ने एक गलत बोला
था बाकी सबका बिल्कुल सही है बिल्कुल सही
अब यह जो दोनों चीजें हैं यह दोनों चीज
डिफरेंट है बिल्कुल डिफरेंट है क्या है
मेटा एक्सप्लोइट एक फ्रेमवर्क है
फ्रेमवर्क या इसको बोलो कलेक्शन ऑफ
स्क्रिप्ट्स दिस इज कॉल्ड मेटास्प्लोइटेबल
[संगीत]
इट्स हैं पेलोड्स हैं नॉप्स
है इवेशन है ठीक है ऑक्सिज है बहुत सारे
ऐसे
स्क्रिप्ट्स है जो उसमें डाले गए हैं इस
मेटास्प्लोइटेबल
जो है ये एक
इंटेंशनली वल्नरेबल मशीन
है ये क्या है एक इंटेंशनली वल्नरेबल मशीन
है तो दोनों में डिफरेंस है दोनों को आप
ध्यान में रखिएगा दोनों सेम नहीं है
बिल्कुल भी नहीं है तो मेटा
स्प्लटर हैं इसका यूज बहुत ज्यादा है बग
बाउटी में भी आप मतलब इसका यूज करेंगे कोई
टेंशन नहीं लेनी है एंड मेटास्प्लोइटेबल
को भी यूज़ करेंगे फिलहाल हम
मेटास्प्लोइटेबल के लिए कर रहे हैं
स्पेशली मेट स् पलटेबल टू के लिए देख रहे
हैं मेट स् पलटेबल टू के लिए कर रहे हैं
ठीक है चलिए तो अब हमारा मेट स् पलटेबल टू
जो है ये यहां पे क्या हो चुका है
एक्सट्रैक्ट हो चुका है मैं इसको क्लोज कर
देता हूं अगेन आपको दिखा देता हूं एक
फोल्डर यहां पे मेटा स् पलटेबल टू हमारा
एक्सट्रैक्ट हो चुका है अब इसको ओपन
करेंगे तो यहां पे मेटा स्टेबल टू लिनिक्स
का यहां पे है इसको ओपन करेंगे तो ये कुछ
फाइल्स आएंगी अब इन फाइल्स में से फिर से
आपको एक vmxnet3 ये फाइल जहां दिख गई ये
आइकन दिख गया कॉन्फिन फाइल है बस आप खुश
हो जाओ क्योंकि अब इसको आप यूज कर सकते हो
अब आपको इसको
कॉन्फिन से वीएम ओपन कर लेंगे एंड वीएम
ओपन करने के बाद आपको अगेन फिर से फाइल पे
जाना है फिर से ओपन पे क्लिक करना है ओपन
पे क्लिक करोगे यहां पे बैक करते हैं मेटा
स्प्ला टेबल में चलते हैं मेटा स्प्ला
टेबल को एक्सपेंड करते हैं एंड मेटा स्पल
टेबल को सिलेक्ट करते हैं ओपन करते हैं इस
कॉन्फिन को
एंड बम
हो
गया हमने मेटा स् पलटेबल को यहां कन्फर कर
दिया अगेन यहां पे आप आएंगे तो अगेन से
एडाप्टर की प्रॉब्लम यहां पे एडिट वर्चुअल
मशीन पे आइएगा एंड इसको भी हम सेम नेटवर्क
एडाप्टर में आ जाते हैं क्यों नेटवर्क
एडाप्टर पहला जो है ना इसको हम ब्रिज कर
देते हैं एंड इसको ओके कर देते हैं एंड यह
हमारा ब्रिज में आ चुका
है इट्स ब्रिज ब्रिज में आ चुका है अब हम
इसको ऑन कर देंगे पावर ऑन करेंगे एंड अगेन
यहीं पे फिर वही गेम है आई कॉपीडब्ल्यूबी
इंटरनेट कनेक्शन होना चाहिए एंड थर्ड
रिक्वायरमेंट आपके पास पेशेंस और बहुत
सारा बहुत सारा पैशन चाहिए फॉर बग बाउंट
एंड साइबर सिक्योरिटी
दैट्ची से चीज मैं आपको सिखाऊंगा समझाऊ हर
एक चीज करूंगा हर एक चीज ठीक है काफी
लोगों को अच्छा मुझे काफी लोगों को आप
लोगों को काली ने आप लोगों ने नहीं यूज
करा होगा काली इंस्टॉल नहीं करा होगा या
यूज नहीं करा होगा अब आप में से मैक्सिमम
लोग काली इंस्टॉल करके आपने रखा होगा एंड
काफी कुछ आपको काली का इंस्टॉलेशन का पता
भी चल चुका होगा काली के बारे में नॉलेज
अगर नहीं होगी उसकी टेंशन मत लो उसका भी
सॉल्यूशन मैंने बता दिया है फिर भी मैं
रिपीट कर दूंगा बट स्टिल मुझे बताओ कितने
लोगों के मशीन में कितने लोगों के पास
पहले काली इंस्टॉल्ड नहीं थी अब इंस्टॉल
वह कर चुके हैं दे हैव इंस्टॉल्ड काली चैट
में बताइए जल्दी
चलिए ओके देन वी हियर आर ऑन द लॉगिन पैनल
एंड आपको अगर आप दिख रहा होगा तो यहां पर
भी दिखा दिखा रहा है यह लॉग इन विथ एमएसएफ
एडमिन एमएसएफ एडमिन एमएसएफ एडमिन एमएसएफ
एडमिन मतलब अब आप एमएसएफ एडमिन एमएसएफ
एडमिन से लॉगिन कीजिए यानी कि लॉगिन भी
एमएसएफ एडमिन पासवर्ड भी एमएसएफ एडमिन तो
चलिए लॉगिन कर लेते हैं एमएसएफ एडमिन एंटर
करते हैं एमएसएफ एडमिन लिनिक्स में जब आप
याद रखिएगा जब आप पासवर्ड डालते हैं यहां
पे तो वहां पे पासवर्ड ना तो टाइप होता है
ना दिखता है वो बस कर्सर ब्लिंक करता है
इट मींस पासवर्ड टाइप हो रहा है ऐसा नहीं
है कि पासवर्ड टाइप नहीं हो रहा है हो रहा
है ठीक है सो डोंट वरी अबाउट ट सो वी आर
लॉक्ड इन बढ़िया वी आर लॉक्ड इन हम लॉगिन
हो चुके हैं अ हम यहां पे क्लियर कर लेते
हैं अब इसकी आईपी देख लेते हैं एंड आईपी
में हमें आईपी मिल गई है हमारे सबनेट की
29.1
83 अब इस पे जब तुम जाओगे इसको मैं स्मॉल
साइज कर देता हूं यहां पे 183 आईपी पे जब
तुम यहां पे चलो देख देखते हैं क्या है
192.1 1883 इस आईपी पे चलके देखते हैं
क्या है तो यहां पे आपको एक डायरेक्टरी
लिस्टिंग मिल जाएगी एंड इस डायरेक्टरी
लिस्टिंग में आपको दिख रहा होगा यहां पे
टीवी की पीएचपी मा एडमिन ये पीएचपी माय
एडमिन इसी का है आप देखो पीएचपी माय एडमिन
आपको मिल गया मेट स्टेबल का यहां पे आपको
दो मटली डे और डीवीडब्ल्यू ए मिल जाते हैं
डीवीडब्ल्यू ए पे चलो यहां पे देखो डैम
वल्नरेबल वे एप्लीकेशन आपको इसके साथ मिल
जा रहे हैं मटली डे जो है ये भी आपको इसके
साथ मिल जा रहा है एंड आपका एक वेब डब जो
है ये आपको यहां पे इस तरीके से वेब डब का
जो डायरेक्टरी है वो मिल जा रही है जो पाथ
है वो मिल जा रहा है ठीक है तो ये सारी
चीजें आपको मिल रही है तो इसके अंदर आपको
मिटल डीवीडब्ल्यू भी मिल जा रहा है एंड
बाकी आप मेटास्प्लोइटेबल का यूज जो है ना
वो हम दूसरे पर्सपेक्टिव से दूसरे तरीके
से करने वाले हैं कुछ अलग तरी से करने
वाले हैं इसका यूज क्योंकि ये काफी ज्यादा
इंपॉर्टेंट है इसका इसकी मदद से ना आपका
काफी कांसेप्ट जो है ना क्लियर हो जाएगा
काफी कुछ आपको मजा आने लगेगा ठीक है तो हम
यहां पे आ चुके हैं बढ़िया से अब यहां पे
जब तुम क्लियर करोगे यहां तुम एलएस करो
यहां पे लिस्ट आ जाएगी जो भी लिस्टेड
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
तो मैं इसका बेस्ट यूज आपको बताऊंगा कि यह
कितना इंपॉर्टेंट है आपका मेटा
एक्सप्लोइटेबल कितनी चीजें ये वल्नरेबल
एप्लीकेशन है बहुत सारी वने बिलिटी है
इसके अंदर बहुत सारी व बिलिटी है तो यह
वल्नरेबल है अब उस पर प्रैक्टिस करोगे तो
आपको आईडिया मिल जाएगा जब आईडिया मिल
जाएगा तो आप रियल वेबसाइट प रियल टारगेट प
सेम आईडिया अप्लाई करोगे एंड वहां पर आपको
रियल बग आपको वैलिड बग मिलेगी जिसको आप
रिपोर्ट
करोगे रिपोर्ट करोगे एंड मैं आपको यकीन के
साथ कह रहा हूं सभी को कि पूरे थ्रू आउट
दिस बग बाउंट जर्नी जो लोग भी सिंसियर हैं
आप में से जो सिंसियर कर रहे हैं क्योंकि
क्या है ना माइंड सेट सबका अलग-अलग होता
है सबके अलग-अलग प्रायरिटीज है कुछ लोग
टाइम पास के लिए भी बग बाउटी करते हैं कुछ
लोग प्रायरिटी देते हैं इसको प्रायरिटी
देने का मतलब क्या हो जाता है कुछ लोग
मतलब चाहते हैं कि नहीं बग बांटी को मैं
सिंसियर सीखूं तो उनके लिए ना एक बात मैं
बोल देता हूं कि आप विद इन थ्री मंथ्स
बग्स फाइंड करना शुरू कर दोगे वैलिड बग भी
मिल सकता आपको अगर आपकी मेथी सही होगी
तो बस साथ में चलो लाइव क्लासेस अटेंड करो
मजा
आएगा ठीक है बस अब आपसे एक सजेशन चाहिए
मुझे सबसे सबसे पूछ रहा हूं प्लीज सजेस्ट
मी आप क्या चाहते हो जो लाइव हम
ट्रेनिंग यह जो कर रहे हैं ना लाइव वाली य
जो लाइव ली कोई से भी कर लो कोई दिक्कत
नहीं ऑर्बिट कोई भी आपकी मर्जी है वो
इसको हम लाइव जब कर रहे हैं तो हम शॉर्ट
रखें शॉर्ट शॉर्ट टॉपिक शॉर्ट शॉर्ट में
टॉपिक छोटे-छोटे में करते चले या एक टॉपिक
लिए कंप्लीट कर थोड़ा लॉन्ग चले जैसे अभी
तो लॉन्ग ही हो रहा है एक घंटे या उससे
ऊपर लॉन्ग ऑलमोस्ट लॉन्ग मानते हैं एक
घंटे के अंदर है तो शॉर्ट माना जाएगा तो
आप क्या चाहते हो एक डेढ़ घंटे का ऐसे चले
या शॉर्ट में चले 30 मिनट से लेके एक घंटे
का टाइम स्लॉट जो हो उस उस तरीके से चले
मुझे बता
दीजिए प्लीज लेट मी
नो मुझे बताइए आई एम सीइंग योर चैट सबके
मैसेज देख रहा हूं
मैं लॉन्ग लॉन्ग
लॉन्ग लंग
भाई तुम लोगों ने लाइक्स की तो बाढ़ ला दी
यार 123 लाइक है 100 लोग देख रहे हैं 123
लाइक है इसके लिए बहुत-बहुत धन्यवाद भाई
लाइक से ना मोटिवेशन मिल जाती है शेयरिंग
से मोटि मिल मोटिवेशन मिल जाती है कमेंट
से मिल जाती है बहुत है
यार लॉन्ग
मतलब काफी लोग लॉन्ग लॉन्ग बोल रहे हैं
भाई ओके ग्रेट ठीक है ओके फैक्ट नंबर वन
ये भी सही है मैं आपको
जो रिसोर्सेस कहां
मिलेंगी बताइए मुझे चैट
में पता है ना आपको आपको अपना हमारा
ऐप पे मिलेगा आपको ऐप पे आप आ जाइएगा ना
यहां पे तो आपको यह जो फ्री क्लासेस एंड
रिसोर्स वाली जो आपको दिख रही है कोर्स
स्टोर टैब में भी आप जाएंगे तो यहां भी
आपको दिख जाएगा फ्री साइबर सिक्योरिटी
क्लासेस एंड रिसोर्सेस इसमें आपको जवाइन
कर लेना है ठीक है ज्वाइन कर लेंगे आप
इसमें आप कंटेंट पे जब जाएंगे जवाइन करने
के बाद तो आपको यहां पे फ्री रिसोर्सेस
मिलेंगी एंड बग बाउंट रिसोर्सेस मिलेगा
ठीक है एंड फ्री लाइव सेशन जो होगा उसमें
आपके डाउट क्लासेस जो होंगे उसमें आपको
मिलेंगे जो डाउट क्लासेस होंगे लाइव आपके
इसी में संडे होंगे संडे टू डे तो आपको
इसी में उनके रिकॉर्डेड वीडियोस मिल
जाएंगे बग बाउंट रिसोर्सेस में आपको बग
बाउंट वाली रिसोर्सेस मिलेगी अभी ओस
चेकलिस्ट है आज मैं इसमें google.ca
google.ca और भी चीजें हैं कुछ वो भी डाल
दूंगा एंड यहां पे फ्री रिसोर्सेस में अदर
रिसोर्सेस अगर कुछ मिलती है जैसे बर्ब शूट
मैंने अपलोड कर रखा है कुछ और टूल या कुछ
और चीजें मिल रही है तो आपको यहां पे मिल
जाएंगी ठीक है तो ये जवाइन करके जरूर
रखिएगा इट्स माय रिक्वेस्ट टू एवरीबॉडी
ठीक है सब ये बिल्कुल करके रखिएगा एंड
ठीक है
whatsapp2 के आसपास इसमें फॉलोअर्स आ चुके
हैं ऑलरेडी आप भी जवाइन कर लीजिएगा एंड
दैट इट ठीक है तो आपको यहां पे सब कुछ
अपडेट वगैरह जो भी चीजें हैं वो सारी
चीजें मिल जानी है ठीक है
चलिए
ओके
तो ओके गट चलिए ठीक है अब यहां पे गाइस
हमने ओ बीडब्ल्यूए को इंस्टॉल किया हमने
मेटा स् पलटेबल को इंस्टॉल किया अब हम जब
और हां एक चीज और अब हम जब नेक्स्ट सेशन
में मिलेंगे तो आपको ये पूरी प्रैक्टिकल
चीजें मतलब बहुत सारी प्रैक्टिकल मिलेंगी
अभी तो पता नहीं क्याक मिलेगा वो मुझे भी
नहीं पता बहुत सारी चीजें हैं यार मैं
अरेंज कर कर के आपको करा रहा हूं पता है
मेरे पास अभी ऐसे ऐसे खच पच ऐसे हॉज पॉज
हो रखा है चीजों का अब उसको मैं अरेंज
करके आपके सामने धीरे-धीरे लेकर आ रहा हूं
ताकि एक अच्छे से प्रॉपर वे में आ जाए ठीक
है बॉब शूट ओपन होने का नहीं हो रहा है
क्योंकि बॉब शूट को आपने सही से कन्फर
नहीं किया उसके लिए आपको जावा इंस्टॉल
करनी है पहले जेडी के जे आरई को आपको पाथ
सेट करना है देन आपको ओपन करना है लोडर के
थ्रू एंड देन आपको एक्टिवेट करना है
मैनुअल एंड देन आपको वहां पे लोडर के थ्रू
वापस से स्टार्ट करना है तो आपका तीन
टास्क मैं आपको प्रोवाइड करता हूं फॉर
एवरीवन थ्री टास्क्स आर देयर
ठीक है सबके लिए तीन टास्क में दे दे रहा
हूं नेक्स्ट क्लास के पहले य टास्क हो
जाने चाहिए अरवाज कोई फायदा नहीं है पहला
कंप्लीट जिनका नहीं हुआ है उनके लिए है यह
कंप्लीट ट्राई हैक
मी ओस टॉप 10 लैब जिनका नहीं हुआ है वह कर
लीजिएगा सेकंड में इंस्टॉल मेटा पलटेबल टू
यह कर लीजिएगा जिनका अभी नहीं हो पाया है
थर्ड में
इंस्टॉल ओस
बीडब्ल्यूए यह आप कर लीजिएगा यह तीन टास्क
है जिन्होंने अभी नहीं किया जिन्होंने कर
लिया कोई बात नहीं आप और भी चीजों को
एक्सप्लोर कीजिए आज के सेशन में जो भी हुआ
आप जानने की कोशिश कीजिए ओस टॉप 10 के
बारे में और रिसर्च कीजिए और पढ़िए मेट
स्प टबल टू के बारे में और एक्सप्लोर
कीजिए ओस बीडब्ल्यूए को और रिसर्च कीजिए
और एक्सप्लोर कीजिए एंड ये आपकी लर्निंग
आपकी जो माइंडसेट है आपका जो मतलब स्किल
है ना वो बहुत ज्यादा एक्सपेंड कर देगा
बहुत ज्यादा डेवलप कर देगा ठीक है ये एकदम
ध्यान रखना है आपको तो ये तीन चीजें आपको
तीन टास्क है आपको करके लाना है तीनों
टास्क आप करके नेक्स्ट क्लास से पहले लाइए
कल एक गैप रहेगा ताकि आप ये सारी चीजें कर
पाए कई लोगों का नेटवर्क इशू होता है कई
लोगों का डाटा प्रॉब्लम हो जाता है तो एक
दिन का गैप तो वैसे भी मिलना है और आप
रिसर्च करके मैं कोई भी क्वेश्चन कर सकता
हूं नेक्स्ट क्लास से पहले ये करके सब लोग
करके लाएंगे मुझे बता दीजिए जल्दी से
एवरीवन विल ब्रिंग दिस टास्क कंप्लीट करके
लाएंगे जिनका भी नहीं हुआ है मुझे बता
दीजिए जल्दी चैट में सभी लोग करके लाएंगे
प्रॉमिस सभी लोग प्रॉमिस करो जल्दी फटाफट
करो एवरीवन डू द प्रॉमिस सभी लोग कंप्लीट
करके लाएंगे भाई जल्दी मुझे
बताइए लेट मी नो
गाइस लिंक फॉर डाउनलोडिंग मेट पलटेबल टू
गल कीजिए डाउनलोड मेटा स्टेबल टू सोर्स
फोज का एक लिंक आएगा उस पर जाइए एंड
डाउनलोड कोई बात नहीं ऑर्बिट कर लेंगे
हम ओके ग्रेट ग्रेट ठीक है बढ़िया और यह
जो हमारे सोशल मीडिया हैंडल्स हैं इसपे आप
हमसे कनेक्ट हो सकते हैं याद रखिएगा
बिल्कुल भी यह हमारा साइबर सिक्योरिटी का
मास्टरी कोर्स है आप इसको जवाइन कर सकते
हैं क्योंकि बहुत इन डेप्थ कोर्स है बहुत
सारे लाइक इसमें मॉड्यूस है जाइएगा de.com
साइबर सिक्योरिटी मास्टरी कोर्स पे
स्क्रॉल कीजिएगा सब डिटेल मिलेंगी एंड यू
कैन गेट टू इट ठीक है और ऐप में आ जाइएगा
एंड दूसरी चीज ये गाइस कि आपको जो भी
क्लासेस अब अगली बार से मिलेंगी वो फुली
फुल्ली फुल ऑन प्रैक्टिकल क्लासेस होंगी
सारी उसमें 10 का कहीं थिरी कांसेप्ट
जहां-जहां होगा मैं आपके लिए लाऊंगा बट
मोस्टली प्रैक्टिकल क्लासेस होंगी लैब्स
एंड रियल टारगेट्स लैब्स एंड रियल
टारगेट्स सब चीजें सब डोमेन न्यूमरेशन भी
स्टार्ट करेंगे रिकन का जो फेज है सबसे
पहला फेज इंटेल जो इंटेल लेना होता है
इंटेलिजेंस अ गैदरिंग आप उसको बोल सकते हो
या एक तरह का ओसिंट बोल लो हम उसको भी
करेंगे इंटेलीजेंटली हम गैदर करेंगे
इंफॉर्मेशन टारगेट के बारे में फिर हम
उसपे न्यूमरेशन करेंगे हम उसपे रिकॉन
करेंगे इंफॉर्मेशन गैदर करेंगे एंड देन हम
हम धीरे-धीरे आगे बढ़ेंगे एक टारगेट के
बारे में इतनी इंफॉर्मेशन कलेक्ट कर लेंगे
कि भैया टारगेट के बारे में ए टू जेड पता
होगा तुम्हें सर से लेके पांव तक उसके
बारे में पता होगा अब जब ये चीज पता होगी
तो तुम्हें वनबिल फाइंड करना तुम्हारे
लिए बाएं हाथ का खेल हो जाएगा ये बाएं हाथ
है हां लेफ्ट हैंड लेफ्ट हैंड से चुटकी
बजाने वैसे चुटकी लेफ्ट हैंड से ही बसती
है शायद राइट हैंड से भी बज जाएगी मेरी
नहीं बसती देखो मेरी राइट हैंड से नहीं
बसती है उतनी लेफ्ट हैंड से बसती है तो ये
लेफ्ट हैंड वाली चुटकी वाली काम हो जाएगी
एंड मस्त वाला तुम्हें मजा आने लगेगा बहुत
शानदार लगेगा ठीक है तो चलिए ये काम कर
लीजिएगा सभी लोग थैंक यू सो मच गाइस
एंड शेयर पीपीटी नहीं दे सकता भाई
एक्सट्रीमली सॉरी माफ कीजिए हाथ जोड़ता
हूं आप सबके सामने एंड मुझे माफ कीजिए
पीपीटी नहीं दे सकता बाकी सब मांग लो
पीपीटी छोड़ के ठीक है चलो तो ट्स ल गाइस
आज के सेशन के लिए अब इस सेशन को
जाते-जाते लाइक लाइक करके जाना जब यह सेशन
तुम एंड करना मतलब लीव करना तो लाइक करते
हुए चले जाना बस बस और अपने दोस्तों के
बीच लिंक पे शेयर कर दो शेयर वाले पे शेयर
का बटन होगा शेयर करो और जहां जहां शेयर
करना है फैला दो यार फैला दो क्योंकि ऐसे
ही तुम अगर सपोर्ट और प्यार बना के रखो ना
फिर देखते जाओ मैं क्या क्या करता हूं मैं
क्या-क्या लाता हूं इस चैनल पे तुम्हारे
दिमाग हिल नहीं जाए ना तो बताना फ्री में
अगर इतना कुछ मिल जाए कहीं पे भी तो जस्ट
लेट मी नो सो थैंक यू फॉर योर वंडरफुल
सपोर्ट गाइज वंडरफुल लव एंड एंड एंड एंड
मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट क्लास में फर्द अपडेट्स
वगैरह के लिए चैनल जरूर जवाइन कीजिएगा
डेस्ट मिलेगी डिनीस अकेडमी को सब्सक्राइब
नहीं करा है तो सब्सक्राइब करो बेल आइकन
को हिट करो यार ईट पत्थर सब मार दो वही सब
फोर डालो ऐसे कौन बोलता है यार उस लाल बटन
पे हथौड़ा मार दो हथौड़ा चला दो ईट पत्थर
सब मार दो ऐसे कोई बोलता तो है youtube0
में ओके चलिए थैंक यू सो मच गाइस
सो एंडिंग दिस सेशन फॉर नाउ आज के लिए बस
इतना ही काफी था आपके लिए करके लाइए टास्क
एंड मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट क्लास में धन्यवाद
थैंक यू थैंक यू एवरीवन और लाइव मेटन
कीजिएगा प्लीज रिकॉर्डेड के भरोसे मत
रहिएगा रिकॉर्डेड बाद में रिपीट कर
लीजिएगा बाद में ये चलेगा रिपीट कर लो बाद
में रिकॉर्डेड
youtube's को मैं कब प्राइवेट करना शुरू
कर दूं मेरा दिमाग भी नहीं जानता तो प्लीज
लाइव में आइए ठीक
है
ओके थैंक यू सो मच गाइस एंड